hey what's up guys my name is chana
welcome back to my gaming fin series so
last time we took a look at a basic
material system more of a discussion as
to how we would build a material system
in the future it's kind of good to start
thinking about that kind of stuff check
out that video if you haven't already
and today we're gonna continue on with
the shader class make it a little bit
more formal right now it's just a basic
class that only works with opengl aren't
abstracted that in any way and it just
kind of does what we wanted to it's I
mean we might as well over an end in
sandbox it's that kind of you know non
integrated into our engine so we're just
gonna clean it up a little bit today and
also talk about how we are going to
actually move it into more of an OpenGL
kind of fashion because unfortunately
the topic of writing a shader class as
you can may probably hopefully imagine
right is something that's very very
difficult because at this stage we have
very little actual functionality to do
with shaders if you were to sit down and
actually write a shader class in your in
hazel right now you would spend a week
on it probably because you need to write
a lot of other systems you tied in with
material systems because in the big
scope of things if you open up like
Unreal Engine source code and you take a
look at how they handle shaders and how
they integrate that with materials and
how all of that works it's immensely
complex it's not just like it's not like
a thousand lines of code that you can
just jam in and everything works it's a
whole architecture it's a whole system
and since hazel is all about me kind of
showing you how everything works step by
step and not only showing all the code
that I'm typing on screen but also
making sure that I'm kind of iteratively
working on hazel meaning that you know
what we have right here right if we just
like take a look for one second what we
have right here with like a triangle and
then all of these quads being rounded
like with every kind of column being a
different color red or blue that kind of
stuff
we could spend three years rewriting
this code refactoring it to do this
because you could do this in like 200
lines maybe of just OpenGL code in one
file and you'd be done right or you
could do this in Unreal Engine or like
frostbite
something like that right you it you
could write it however you like it's so
complex so I just want to get that into
your heads that doing something like
this from the get-go and immediately
writing this amazing amazing engine with
an amazing materials this is an amazing
shader system that is not something that
we can actually physically do if we were
to do it again it would take a hundred
videos and everyone will probably lose
interest in this series because we've
been making little squares for a hundred
videos so I'm just kind of trying to
structure it in a way that is both
interesting to you guys but also shows
kind of almost like you know a basic
engine all the way up to like something
kind of industry standard something like
triple-a so that's the goal of this
series just to get up yes anyway patron
home folks have shown a best way to
support this series if this stuff is
it'll be boring for you and you want to
see like some physically based rendering
lesson like an actual kind of proper
like model viewer which has a real 3d
render but like a camera and everything
integrated in into it then check out
patreon competition oh if you do help
support a series you'll get access to
source code where I've already achieved
all of that and that'll kind of help
accelerate your learning a little bit
and that is also what we're working
towards with this series so today what
are we gonna do well step one is gonna
be to refactor the shader class very
slightly just to get it out of the idea
of being OpenGL only because right now
if you look at shader or a chat about
CPP it has OpenGL card in it it's tied
to OpenGL we want to get rid of that
Association
second of all we want to add more
uniform functions so at the moment we
can only I think we have a map for that
we can upload and a float for because
that's what we used for this color we're
gonna make it so that we have all the
uniforms that we actually need to upload
and then third of all I actually want to
add some kind of colour picker to our
GUI UI like I said last time so that you
can actually pick the color of all of
these squares just for simplicity we'll
probably make all the squares the same
color but you'll be able to actually use
a color picker in the engine to pick
what color you want the squares to be so
that will kind of just show dynamic
uniforms being updated as you change the
color and that should be kind of a good
test on the topic of uniforms I don't
wanna talk about uniforms too much as I
mentioned last time uniform
something that a proper uniform system
needs a proper material system because
typically what you would be doing is
basically using the material API when
you bind a material that when the
renderer actually binds a material you
would typically just take all of the
uniform values that you need from both
the renderer and from the actual
material that you're using and then
upload them as kind of one buff or one
continuous buffer right into the shader
right because you want to transmit all
that data to the GPU kind of in one
batch that is not what we're doing right
now that requires a little bit of setup
we in a proper renderer when a problem
material system all that kind of stuff
and that's coming in the future very
soon you guys seem to avert it for 3d
and we'll have another poll as well just
to make it more formal because the
YouTube honestly the polls on the
YouTube videos I really hate like they
just give you no data so I'll make a
propyl poll I think on my actual YouTube
page I was like the text post because
you can also do that and that'll have
like that'll be like an actual poll
they'll be linked in the description
I'll mention it at the end of the video
as well but um that would be like an
actual poll where you can leave comments
and discuss it and it'll just be like
kind of in the context of a poll and you
can see how many people voted and all
that stuff so that will kind of be the
formal last like kind of last decision I
guess that gets made us to if we do 2d
or 3d first anyway today let's do all
this uniform stuff let's let's add all
the uniform functions that we need for a
panellist separated into an OpenGL class
and let's see if we can change the color
of these squares dynamically okay so
first thing we're gonna do is take a
look at that shader class so as I
mentioned if we go to our shader class
this is shader dot CPP if we look at
where it's located that's shaded or CVP
thing so I go to hazel whoops control
files is what I wanted to do and we just
quickly take a little where it is you
can see that it's right here it's in
hazel renderer shader
what is this this is a API independent
an API agnostic API an API agnostic API
a render API agnostic hazel API all
right hard to say and doesn't make sense
but the point is all of this code should
be completely generic and you can see
that in the case about vertex array in
the case of both index buffers and
vertex
we do a switch to determine which API we
use whereas shader does none of that
shed it just has pure GL code in it it
has no switching it's just a full class
it's that's not one that's not what we
want at all so the first step is gonna
be to go into platform again to go into
OpenGL and then I'm gonna add a new file
two new files one's gonna be called
OpenGL or can GL shaders H okay and then
I'll also make a OpenGL shader dot CPP
file and then what I want to do is the
CPP file we're basically just gonna
let's go to the shadow file let's open
up a potato class and I'm just gonna
copy everything because it's basically
basically what we've written here is an
OpenGL specific shared a class and I'll
do the same for the CPP file and it's
gonna copy it straight off and paste it
into here
alright that's much better so now what
we'll do is make it specifically an
OpenGL shader class like we did with
vertex array with vertex buffer all that
stuff we don't need to include this
stuff but we do need to make sure that
we include hazel renderer and shader dot
H okay this obviously becomes OpenGL
shader the destructor will also be
virtual bind and unbind will end up
being kind of virtual pom store
overrides look at that and then this
stuff we're gonna keep in this class
because we don't want to expose this
kind of API to the shader now this is a
this involves a little bit of discussion
so we'll probably just talk about it as
we go but essentially and we'll do the
same thing that we do for all of our
like API independent clauses so if you
take a look at like you know a buffer or
something don't H you'll see that that
we also have you know we have like a
virtual destructor we've got um bind
unbind and virtually done equals to
false here which I guess we can do for
here as well instead of this but um you
can see that we've got we've just got
like um we've got our like virtual
destructor and a bunch of virtual
functions that are pure virtual and nor
data members in here and then like us
static create function so that's exactly
the pattern that we're gonna be
following for our shared class so this
will just be your virtual this
disappears because we don't want to
expose it what we will in what we will
in fact have and this is already done in
the hazel development branch what we
will actually have is just like a
virtual void you know upload uniform
buffer right but this will be a little
bit more complicated because it will be
different for like vertex shaders it
will be different for like material
uniforms versus renderer uniforms
because they might have get uploaded at
different frequencies therefore they
might be different like actual different
buffers inside the GPU there's a whole
lot of actual stuff that needs to get
written for that to happen but that's
just a little bit of a peek into the
future if you're wondering how on earth
this system works now you'll note that
we do not expose anything into this
shader class we don't have we don't have
our upload uniform at 4 or float 4
exposed at all so how do we currently
with this system upload uniforms you may
be asking yourself so the answer to that
as you'll see is we're just going to end
up whilst we will create a shader and
it'll be a shader pointer what we will
actually do is basically cast that
shader into an OpenGL shader because
clearly it's gonna be an OpenGL shader
object at this point because that's the
only renderer API we support and then by
the time we start supporting other Nrap
eyes we'll actually have that material
system in place so we'll never have to
cast so that makes sense and that's kind
of a way for us to skip ahead but also
be able to retain that functionality
without writing a whole bunch of code
that will never ever need that's it that
is our whole shader class now we need a
static shader pointer create function
now what do we have inside our OpenGL
shader we had a constructor which takes
in a vertex source and fragment come
source so that's exactly what we'll
paste in to create I'm gonna open up
vertex array dot CPP and steel basically
all the code
in there and that's going to replace the
code inside a shaded LCVP obviously
willing we include shaded on age and
renderer we'll also need to include for
render API and then we'll instead of
this will include OpenGL shader inside
the platform alright so that is looking
pretty good
obviously we replace this with OpenGL
shader and we fill in the gaps
so this becomes a create function which
takes a shader pushes on in the shadow
namespace and then we have that's all
correct vertex source and fragment
source ends up dragging sauce ends up
here that looks pretty good to me so it
doesn't seem very happy because I've got
a semicolon at the end if you try and
just control f7 that compile this file
see if that works it does great ok so
that's that's basically the change that
we made so right now obviously will be
creating I don't OpenGL shader point 2
every time we do this on the topic of
pointers I'm getting really quite sad at
seeing these raw pointers absolutely
everywhere in the code right now they
should basically be some kind of form of
reference counted objects so in other
words in our case without writing our
own that would be a shared pointer I'm
really keen to move over into that
system we might even do that next
episode because as I mentioned I am
getting a little bit annoyed with this
and the more of this we write the more
we'll have to replace later you'll see
how we do that when we do cover that
because I'm and again this stuff is done
obviously in hazel dev already but um
maybe that's worth doing next time so
potentially there will be the next
episode in fact I think I will because
it's just kind of like this almost
boilerplate code that just needs to be
written and then we can just forget
about it's kind of like the core hazel
library stuff that needs to be written
the core stuff ok fantastic so that
that's it that is 100% the end of this
class this renderer ID obviously gets
removed because the shadow class should
have no data and we don't need we don't
really need GL m here at all nor do we
it's normally string again
cool so I think she'll shatter already
has that to be honest which I can't
search for annoyingly um okay so we have
we just have shader so we do need GL m
just because we have this stuff over
here so that is looking pretty good
obviously we need to do some planning to
find replace stuff here so Open GL
shader
I'll quickly just replace share to : :
with OpenGL shader : : inside this
document and then patched up these two
things the constructor and the
destructor all right um that I think is
about it for what we need to do here so
what I'll do is probably test this out
now if we go to sandbox app we currently
you'll see hopefully that if I compile
Hazel especially if I compile hazel but
it we shouldn't even need to compile all
those happen if we take a look at where
we've written our shaders you can see
the hours are popping up you'll see that
we can't actually create hazel in the
same way and one last thing that I'll do
actually is that's fine as in the render
we'll deal with that in a minute
so inside the sandbox a Pacific beat you
can see that we can actually create a
hazel hair anymore because we can't go
new shader just like we can't go new
vertex array because it's an abstract
class so we'll have to do hazel shadow
create just like just like we have to do
with all of our other kind of renderer
like for resources ok there we go so we
create that instead of doing it and then
we have a fantastic problem that we have
to deal with sort and the same thing by
the way is inside the renderer class
when we try to upload these uniforms
shader is currently a shared pointer and
that is off shader of type shader what
we need to do is actually cast it into
an OpenGL shader now we know it's an
OpenGL shader because that's the only
thing it could possibly be and by the
time it could be like a DirectX trader
or a Vulcan shader we will have far far
like rewritten the system gone rid of it
and made it actually abstract but since
we haven't right now we basically have
to cast
this sir to do that using you know
proper state balls boss I guess we'll
have to do either a static or dynamic us
technically speaking we could easily do
a static cast because we know what it is
we don't need to do any kind of
validation to make sure it's that but
just for the sake of being like you know
nice I guess we'll do a dynamic pointer
cast into your OpenGL shader like that
so sed dynamic pointer class cost and
then the the type of motor constitutes
so we'll have to include obviously
platform platform or conceal and OpenGL
shader for that to work and I'll just
copy this and paste it into here okay so
now what we're doing and and in the
future we can easily just search for you
know neccessity dynamic point to cough
it up just search basically this string
and then replace that all with just you
know not casting at all because we won't
need anymore even though that doesn't
make sense because well to remove this
function anyway because upload a new
format for is not an abstract function
it's a GL shader only function great so
that's what we end up with and we have
to do the same thing in sandbox app in
this case we're going to change the way
the system works though so it'll be a
little bit different
mr. what we need to do is and the thing
is this doesn't get bound ever so we do
a uniform way of binding not a great
idea the reason that may have worked
before and did work before it's just
because I think that's is that the only
shader we have I'm actually quite
surprised that works to be honest
because the shader was never bound and
that's a bit dodgy but let's bind the
shader so we'll do em flat color shader
bind and again we'll have to just copy
that
I'm gonna do a few things we'll have to
copy this include from the renderer into
your color sample like that and then
we'll have to since that's actually
quite a hazel I might put it like first
like that and then we'll have to do
hazel
OpenGL shader customs right type there
we go bind and then what we'll do is
we'll actually upload so red color blue
color that's all great what I'll do is
I'll actually create a member here
because we're going to tie this in with
ayam GUI as I mentioned this would be a
GLM back 3 M square color I set this
equal to point two point three point
eight I put it before I'll just have it
as a vector three I mean the Alpha is
going to be zero so we might as well
just have it as the back three which
means we'll have to add the right
function so we have this is a we'll do
the upload here so we'll have to do an
upload uniform upload three which we
don't have yet but we'll the name will
remain as you underscore color and then
the value will be M square color okay
I've already written everything else
we'll get rid of this stuff and just do
the transform in the position inside
here so this will just kind of again if
we had a material
it would be in the material but we don't
so it's here but when we have materials
in the future will rewrite this will get
rid of the rotor color and the blue
color from here because we don't need
them anymore and then the final thing is
we just create all these functions so
let's go ahead and make that happen
so inside opengl theta we're going to
basically duplicate this a bunch of
times we'll have upload flow upwards or
2.3 and flow fall will probably have an
int as well so upload uniform int we'll
definitely need that for things like
samplers when we need to upload doors in
two in three in four you probably won't
make functions for that just yet we
could definitely understand I think what
or not they'd be used for and in three
would probably be quite useful for like
bone indices but again we're not dealing
with animation anytime soon so I think
that's too useful right now so I'll just
I'll deal with that in the future as we
need it I'll do math for either because
that's going to be useful okay so we've
got all this sorted out now so we've got
all these I can just right click here
and use visual assist to create all of
these things
okay and then back here and soon put
them in the right order which is great
what I'll do is just copy this code
absolutely everywhere so this you this
location should as I mentioned last
episode should already be here because
we should have passed a shared it got
all the shader values out will have
we'll deal with that in more depth in
the future for sure but for now we'll
just get the location every single time
which we shouldn't really notice any
kind of performance decrease from that
even though it isn't the most efficient
thing to do just because we're not
dealing with any kind of large-scale
rendering at the moment so don't worry
too much about that if you are slightly
worried okay to F and 3m what you could
do is actually cache these locations as
like a quick thing you could either like
retrieve a list of active uniforms from
OpenGL but a technique that a lot of
people tend to do is actually cache the
uniforms and like it in like a map like
a hash map so that you don't bet like
under the hash map the hash map is based
on the name of the uniform and then the
kid the natural value it's the location
so you just easily kind of retrieve the
location only once and cache that value
and then reuse it since the locations
not going to change I actually have a
video I think that yesterday I probably
released a video on that I've made the
video yep I'm gonna make it and then
release it and actually this video will
be released after I released the other
video which is weird because I haven't
made the other video yet but long story
short OpenGL caching uniforms video up
there check it out if you haven't
already if you want more details about
how to cash these uniforms and stuff
because I thought I'd make a specific
OpenGL series video about that okay sir
value this becomes value X value dot Y
kiss in case I'm growing a little bit
too fast no I'm not following along all
I'm doing here is just creating very
very basic functions just pretty much
the same but they actually deal with
different types so in otherwise we're
dealing with a three component back to
here to convert it back to a one
component of X for just a flirt and then
like a focal part it back to like a fact
full which is just for floats that we're
uploading to the GPU
I'm in the form of a uniform so
we basically can put any type of data we
want and not just float fours and Matt
force which is what the the other thing
that we could do before so this becomes
3 Fe and that is literally the only
thing that changes amazing okay
really simple make sure that you don't
make any mistakes 4 3 2 1
sounds good and one I of course for the
integer ok that's it that's all we have
to do now we have all of these functions
and we can obviously use all of them
like upload uniform flow at 3 for
example should it be completely fine
here's the function ok so that's how
that works let's go ahead and add this M
square color vector
to our I'm going controls really really
easy to do well I think we've done that
before and I'm gooey but I'll show you
how simple it is but basically just do I
am gooey begin to make a new window I'll
call this when this window settings and
then every I'm good again needs to have
an IM gooey end as well and then in
between that we put basically a list of
UI controls that we want so what we'll
do is we'll make a I am going to color
edit 3 which is just a little kind of
color edit UI control that we can click
on to bring up a color picker
we'll call this our square color and
we'll give it a GL M value pointer which
is going to be our square color just
like that okay and for value pointer I
think we need an include which is this
one I'm just doing it from OpenGL shader
just like that and that's it like these
three lines of code are going to give us
a nice little UI it's that we can change
the square color at runtime and
everything else you work
let's hit f5 and see what happens ok so
that did not work as expected all of our
squares are actually black which is
fantastic but you can see that at least
they are in the proper positions which
means that obviously the transformation
matrix and all that stuff works so for
some reason our flat color shader did
not seem to work with this so let's take
a look at this oz effect for so we
change it to a vector 3 make sure that
you don't forget that change and then
IRA Keeler just to effect for you color
and then one
for the Alpha let's hit f5 and this
should now work alright as you can see
we have our hazel engine running with
this kind of UI control here with the
square color so what we can do is now
just click on this brings up a color
picker and you can see that we can
change it to really any color we want
and there's all of the squares are
updated with that car so definitely very
cool and it shows that all of our
uniforms are in fact working dynamically
alright so I hope you guys enjoy this
video if you did you can hit that like
button you can also help support the
series by going over to patreon icon for
- that show know and get access to a lot
of really cool things I've started doing
this new thing on patreon where I
actually make exclusive videos just for
patrons so this isn't like some kind of
massive like conspiracy of oh my gosh
Jonah is suddenly releasing all of his
like a really good content just for
patrons behind a paywall no no no what
I'm actually doing is just making little
videos as I work on the real video it's
just with little notes so while I'm
developing hazel dev right which is kind
of my personal hazel development branch
which you can also access through
patreon which is where I've got like the
PBR Endre and all that stuff or I'm just
kind of just thinking about another
video that I'll make I'll make kind of
like a development log there's just like
hey guys so this is what I'm thinking of
doing I'll just type out some code to
make sure it works you know this is what
I've been doing in a hazel dev this is
what the code looks like in hazel dev
this is what I'm thinking about doing
for the next episode of the game engine
series for specifically the hazel does
public that kind of stuff for its like I
mean last time I released it was like a
25 minute video of me just having a
casual conversation it's almost like a
meeting or something that I'm just kind
of like discussing with you guys like
hey this is what I'm doing most of the
content that I say that does eventually
make its way to YouTube videos but this
is just like a kind of exclusive like
behind-the-scenes look and more of like
kind of a discussion where you guys can
also leave comments and make suggestions
and like it's just something that I drew
kind of as I work on stuff back in my
office so if you're interested in that
doesn't help support to get those videos
by the way it's like three dollars a
month it's the lowest patron tier and
you get access to all those patreon
videos I'm trying to do like one or two
a week but at least one a week so
definitely try that out and helps about
the series because your generosity makes
this
kind of stuff possible and I love doing
this kind of stuff so much so next time
as I mentioned probably take a look at
reference counting and that kind of
stuff because the more we leave it the
more work we'll have to do later might
not be the most thrilling episode but
it's just core kind of engine stuff that
really doesn't need to get done and as I
mentioned before there's going to be one
final poll just to determine whether or
not we're gonna do 2d and 3d just so you
guys know and you can check that out but
just looking at the last video it was
like two-thirds of you voted for 3d and
one-third of you voted for 2d so it is
very likely going to be 3d so I've
already started planning 3d actually and
that's probably the direction that will
actually take but again one final poll
they'll be description and it'll be a
link in description if you go to my
channel it's in like the discussion page
some of you may have already seen it pop
up on your like feed because I'm just
gonna publish it as like a poll
through YouTube so definitely make sure
that you go there and vote and also
leave a comment like suggesting maybe
why you voted this and why you want that
so that you can get more people on board
to vote for what you want and this will
kind of be the final decision as to
which way we take this hazal youtube
series hope you guys enjoy this video
I'll see you next time goodbye
[Music]